[Music]
what is just keep living and what was
her inspiration for it just keep living
is is something that came to me a few
days after my father passed away in 92
and I was working on my first film dazed
confused so there's something that came
to me and trying to cope with him
physically no longer being here then I
started applying just keep living to
anything I couldn't life and I couldn't
find any where that it didn't fit I
wanted to start a foundation and do some
charitable work Matthew McConaughey's
foundation focuses on helping
underprivileged high school kids a lot
of these high schools are kids that are
living in poverty future percent dropout
rate and we offer them a safe place to
go after school two times a week where
they set goals for exercise nutrition
you have to do community service after
you give back for own community now the
actor has teamed up with Samsung to help
bring more awareness to the foundation
Samsung gives invests in local charities
across the nation and as directly
supported our foundation just keep
living foundation since 2010 EG was with
Matthew and wife Camilla at the frame
gallery for a Samsung event where they
showcased the new state of the art frame
TVs or what makes the frame really
magical in the home is if you turn off
your TV the art just comes back on I
think it's really important to bring
that kind of inspiration into people's
lives this is a great event tonight to
bring attention to bring awareness
they're helping out our phone foundation
and like you said the shines alight we
talked about awareness
Matthew is also helping with the
hurricane relief efforts in his home
state of Texas is combating one thing on
top of the other and again you sit there
you go what I want to do something work
with what time that Camille and I had
we hosted a few events and a t-shirt you
were doing a t-shirt as well that
proceeds were going to make sure I made
sure when I went from jogging on the
Hudson River to where that in case the
paparazzi got me but just keep just keep
giving just keep living he's got a Texas
flag on it because as we all know the
this will be back page news in the next
month four people died after mm-hmm
these events than during yeah because of
things they've necessities they don't
have
[Music]